one of the things that's always
fascinated me is bits
or bit blitz or
the blit operation and things that it's
very referred to depending on which
computer system you're using which
operating system what time of day it is
that sort of thing this was an algorithm
that was developed at xerox park back in
the 70s by diana mary and dan ingles and
a few others and it's an algorithm that
was used right through the 70s through
the 80s and even into the 90s
on computer graphics hardware across all
sorts of different computers and
interpreting in software and things and
so i thought it'd be fun to have a look
at what this algorithm is used for why
it's sometimes implemented in software
why it's even faster if you implement it
in hardware or can be faster if you
implement it in hardware and things are
just why it's so useful in computer
graphics operations
if you bought a computer in the 80s you
may well see that listed on the features
was that it had a blitter chip in there
famously with the commodore amigos one
of the things that they claimed made it
so good and then it was added by atari
into the atari st line a bit later on as
well
and that is just a hardware
implementation of the same algorithm
that xerox park and others have been
using right back to the 70s so it's not
something new that came from commodore
or amiga or any of those things it's
just implementing a standard algorithm
in hardware because it works faster if
you do it in hardware then if you do it
in software so what does this algorithm
do well it's very very simple it copies
blocks of memory from one location to
another but it has the ability to
combine those two blocks or three blocks
depending on the way you implement it
in specific ways and depending on how
you combine those things you can get
interesting patterns appear on screen so
it's mainly used for graphics operations
although you can use it
for other things the atari falcon for
example uses it to speed up hard disk
access because your hard disk appears as
a location in memory and so you can copy
from that location to other bits of
memory very very quickly if you use the
blitter chip to do it but in general
it's used for
heart
in general it's used for graphics
operations so let's remind ourselves
about how a computer would represent a
graphics display in its computer's
memory and we're going to think about a
very very simple one we're going to sort
of
go down to the bare bones we're going to
have a set of pixels well let's just do
with four by four so i don't have to
draw so many squares so one two
three four rows and four
columns of pixels so we can reference
any pixel on that by giving it a number
so we've got 0 1 2 3 for the rows and 0
1 2 3 for the columns and then we can
start to draw shapes in there so if i
want to sort of square
i can fill in the
first two pixels on the first row
filling the first two pixels
on the second row we're going to keep
this simple we're going to have pixels
that are either black or white
on off
that's fine we can draw things and we
can start to draw interesting patterns
let's do the same here
but we need a way to encode that into
the computer's memory and the way that
we do that
is that we can convert
these pixels
into bits into the bits of the
computer's memory and we can do that so
okay a black pixel is going to be one
because it's set and a white pixel is
going to be zero because it's not set so
we could take the first row and so we're
going to represent that as a one bit
because we've set it a one bit because
we've set it a zero bit because we
haven't set it in a zero bit because we
haven't set it next line is exactly the
same
and then we can do the same again for
this line not set not set so zero zero
set that's a one not set
that's a zero
we've got an interesting pattern i don't
know what it is and then on the last
line not set not set
not set
set and so we can convert
the patterns that we've created into a
binary number and then we could store
that in the computer's memory so this
would be the equivalent of size 12
and 1 and we could store them
in the computer's memory if we want more
pixels so people say go to have 8 pixels
we'd use 8 bits if we wanted 16 pixels
we'd use 16 bits
2 bytes and so on to store that and what
we do is we'd store this going starting
from the top
of the screen with the first line we
store all the bits that may represent
that so let's say we've got a 640 by 480
screen we'd have 640 bits
80 bytes worth of information 80 times
80 to 648 bits in the byte 8 pixels in a
byte 80 bytes would represent that line
then the next 80 bytes in memory would
be the next line of pixels
and that will continue for 480
lines and 32k of memory later you've got
the data for your screen
now that works very nicely you can store
it in memory the other thing is it's
actually very easy to build the display
hardware to display that
on screen because you can take a byte or
a word of memory at a time
load it into the sort of same shift
registers that mike was talking about
last week when you're talking about
linear feedback shift registers you can
hardly implementation that you load the
byte in and then you clock out
each of the bits one by one out of the
shift register
and that's the signal that you can send
to your tv or whatever monitor device
you're using to display things on screen
so this approach works really nicely for
storing data in a form that we can
manipulate because we can just change
the bits to change the pattern
so for example if we wanted to
invert
this pattern here so rather than having
black black white white we had white
white black black we could take the bits
run them for a not gate and we'd invert
it so we get 0 0
1 1 0 zero one one
one one zero one
one one one zero and if we draw
uh square out again so there we are so
we can manipulate those bits to change
the pattern that we've got on screen and
what we find is that you can use various
operations to
alter the bits as they're stored in
memory to create different graphical
effects so for example if we wanted to
draw a character on screen let's say we
wanted to draw a character let's go for
a letter a and i'm going to draw an
eight by eight this time so we'll go a
bit bigger so we can represent this
and we've got a letter a
as an 8-bit character and the same way
we can convert this into a series of
bytes that we can store in memory so
we've got zero across the top because
none of them are set i'm speeding things
up we've got 60 in there if we convert
it to binary
64 plus 2 that's 66 66 that's 126. we'll
go with that 66
66 and we've got zero and we can fast
forward through that as well and we've
got a series of bytes that can represent
a character a and we can display that
character on screen just by going to
some location and writing those bytes
into the memory that's representing our
screen one row after another so we have
to write it at the right location the
right byte in memory then add on the
length of the screen line as much talked
about in some of the videos on images
write the next bite in and then we go
down and that would appear on screen is
this like is this what's known as the
screen buffer yeah exactly this is the
sort of the way that the screen buffer
is it's just literally a series of bits
that represent in memory and actually
one of the things you find is when
people started to add color
rather than say using two pixels next to
each other which you could do or three
pixels four pixels to represent
they use the same idea of having a
bitmap display but then they put another
one behind it and you read the color by
looking at the first plane of bits and
the second plane of bits behind it so
this might have a zero that might have a
one in the same location for a pixel so
that's the color of the pixel is zero
one
color two so we can
write those bytes into memory at that
location and that would display them on
the screen
except
what we'd end up doing is
we would replace what was on the screen
beforehand so we'd always get a letter a
but it would all be on a white or black
background depending on what way you've
got the colors but what we could do is
we could use a different way of storing
them so we could actually say
and i'm going to be clever here just to
try and illustrate this if i can figure
it out
let's say we wanted to
draw a line to show that this had been
crossed out
and we could do that by
having a line and we'd represent that
just by a series of
pixels
one after the other
going in a diagonal pattern and we could
work out the bit pound for that and
start off with 128 64 32 i'm not going
to bother going through that
so what we want to do
is to overlay that on top if i just take
the numbers and write them we don't
overwrite what was here
but what i can do is i can take the
number i've got here
and combine it with the bits that i've
got already on the screen
so what i can do is i can take the
number here
which is 128
combine it with the number we've got
here
using the or operation and basically all
i'm doing here
is oring every bit here with the
equivalent bit
in the other one
so that would then become 0 or 128 is
and then that would set that pixel there
leaving the rest
things do the same with the other one so
we get 64 here 60 or 64.
becomes 124
in that case
we now do the next one we would have 32
and we'd all that
in there 60 or 32 is going to be 96
and so on and we can work out the
numbers and we could do the same thing
so
just to check so the all operation there
is saying if it's not already a one make
it a what yeah so it's exactly the same
boolean logic that you've seen in
computer science before you take two
bits
in the same position you run them
through an or gate if either bit is set
or both bits then the output is one
otherwise the output is zero if both
bits are zero
so you could do that you could also do
the same using and and you'd get
interesting effects effects where you'd
mask off some pixels so you only have
the pixels set
where both the original image and the
new image had a pixel set there and if
you draw the right shape there you could
say have one image it was a circle
another image which was something and
them together and you'd end up with
whatever the first image was now in a
circle so what we find is is that by we
can write software which can combine
the things and to draw things on the
screen if we want to
copy a value one and just replace it we
can just store the values in there if we
want to overlay them we can or them if
we want to sort of mask them we can use
an and to do that and various other
things we can invert them by running
them through a not gate so various
boolean operations boolean logic
operations can have interesting effects
as to what appears on screen
now you can write the software to do
that but what actually turns out is is
that most of these operations
end up
looking the same
let's say i want to copy
one this is my screen an image over here
let's say we've got a picture of a dog
that's my image
and i want to copy it
to appear
down here now how would i do that well i
would start off reading in the bytes and
make up this dog in the corner look at
the number poppy zero there and i would
copy the same bytes there then do it for
the next one along
the next one along the next one along
the next one along next one in fact you
do it bit by bit because you're copying
the bits
and things and then eventually you'd get
to the bits that sort of make up the
dog
i don't know if that looks like a dog
let's have a little bit more
it's vaguely like grommet isn't it
it's looking straight and on if i have a
couple of eyes it might be more
you're testing my graphical skills here
there we are so that's a dog and we copy
it by basically copying all the bits
from one location
to you and to do that we can basically
we find out where in memory this starts
and we find out how many
bits it's taking up
and we copy those bits
here to this new location where we're
putting them well we find out where this
where this starts in memory and we copy
them to these things and we start
writing the bits there
now the interesting thing is that
you can have two rectangles here two
regions and they might be different
sizes so you might say copy this
rectangle here to this rectangle here
which is slightly smaller and in that
case you want to work out okay this
one's smaller i'll stop when i get to
the edge of this one then move on to the
next line see you can work out we'll
keep them the same size just to simplify
things so we can do that in a for loop
we go across the top line copying all
the bits one by one
and to speed it up we probably copy the
bytes
but the problem with that is is that if
this that's fine if the they line up on
a multiple of eight or a multiple of 16
if your computer works in short words
and things and so on but if this is say
position eight we can read it easily we
want to put it at a position
let's say this is a
shall we say
that doesn't line up to a multiple of
eight the nearest multiple of eight is
320. so 320
bytes in from the middle of the screen
but actually we want the bits to start
two pixels further on
so actually what we need to do is take
the eight bits from here
move them here we don't want to write
them exactly we sort of shift them right
uh by two which means two bits fall out
the edge and we have to keep track of
them
and then we write that byte into memory
and then we've got two bits left over
from the previous by which we need to
get to now be in the top two bar bits of
that byte and we copy the next bit
and then we so we end up we can write
the software to do this it's relatively
straightforward code and we just step
through this copy them across
and then we go on to the next line we
update our pointer here to get back to
the position here we update the pointer
from the rectangle here to get to the
next line and we do exactly the same
thing
and if you want to cop write a character
on the screen you do this but you just
store the values
if you want to
overlay them you do the same thing
because this source rectangle doesn't
actually have to be on the screen it
just has to be somewhere in memory and
the same operation applies it could be a
different shape screen you just add
different values on
and so on so what the bit blit algorithm
does is it basically is a way of
automatically taking one source
rectangle so we can take all the pixels
from here and we describe where it is
with us things from where it is in
memory because
memory's memory
the way we make it into an image is the
way that we describe that memory and
treat it in our software and then the
hardware that displays it so this
doesn't have to be the same location in
memory as long as we know where it is we
know how long
the width of the screen is with that
block is in pixels and bytes and things
we can describe that and as we know
where this is going they can overlap and
things we can then copy it if we just
want to copy it from one location to the
other we read a byte right at the right
position if we want to overlay them we
read a byte
read a byte from the source image all
them together
write them back having shifted things if
we need to to get them in the right
place if we want to mask them we do the
same with an end the bitly algorithm
just generalizes this so you can then
use this algorithm to copy from one
region somewhere in the computer's
memory to another
uh applying whatever operation whatever
combination of logical operations you
want to do and as we said there's only a
small number that actually makes sense
there's only 15 that you can do so
there's only 16 that you can do two of
which set things to all be zero or all
be one
which you don't really need to do
because
you can just copy from a black bit or a
white bit of the screen
and so on so yeah there's a limited
number that actually makes sense but
there's only 16 that you could possibly
do
anyway
so that's the bit algorithm it's just a
way of copying things about and
combining them to create fancy images
now why did this all get implemented
in hardware
well the problem is is that when you
start to write software to do this you
actually have to write
a program that's run by the cpu
that does this thing you could think
about a very trivial
operation where you start okay get the
first pixel
work out where that is on screen work
out which bit is representing that read
that bit
move that so it's in the right place to
set the bit on the screen at the other
thing
combine it with the bit that's already
there based on the operation you want to
do
and things if you do that there's a
famous paper by rob pike describing how
this works and they implemented it on a
6 8 000 back in the 80s it took 8
minutes to copy a screen
which is a bit slow so but you can do it
but there's ways you can speed it up as
we said you could read a bite at a time
and shift that bite to the right place
and then write a bite at a time you'll
get eight times faster because you're
reading eight bytes or you can do it in
sixteens if you've got 16 bit machine
and so on and get 16 times faster
roughly but if you actually look at
what's happening if you were to write a
program that was do it
the way the cpu works is the cpu is
going to read the instruction it's going
to execute particularly on the cpus of
the time these days you've got caches as
we talked about in there which will
actually sort of save it having to read
that from memory again but the way this
operation works does
cause some interesting issues with the
cache uh and operations if you don't
have separate instruction and data
caches because you're reading lots of
data and so you're going all over memory
and things so it's not cash friendly
so you read an instruction which says
load a byte from memory you load it you
manipulate it and you store it but each
of those operations requires another cpu
instruction so actually what end up
happening is that your cpu is spending
most time is fetching the instructions
to execute
rather than
fetching
the graphics images and manipulating
them
so what people did because this is
actually a very structured algorithm
it's
read by from memory read byte from
memory
combine bytes write result back to
increment pointers
repeat until you get to the end of the
line
increment pointers in a slightly
different way
rinse and repeat for the next line and
so on it's actually very easy
to build this in hardware
and so what the blitter chips were in
the amiga what the blizzard ships was in
the atari sc and other computers were
hardware implementations
of
the
bit blit algorithm and by implementing
it in hardware you can get a huge speed
increase because that chip is
all it does is bit bit operations so it
doesn't have to fetch the instruction to
say load the bike from memory then load
the bike it just knows that it's loading
it from memory loads that bright loads
this bike from the destination combines
and writes it back out to the
destination gets on with the next one
it's
it's it's a fixed processor it does one
thing and it does it very very quickly
but also if we think about we talked
about how if this is at pixel 8 and
we're moving it to pixel 322 we have to
shift it
about and then we've got the bits left
over and things
you can start to do clever things in
your design let's draw out
uh
a register just a bit memory inside the
chip with eight
one two three four
five six seven eight what we can do is
read in
each bit from that byte into memory now
we could have a shift register where we
actually shift it about but there's
actually a clever way that we can do
this which is what some of the bitter
chips
did
is that we can have
another
eight bits and i'm going to draw these
slightly smaller
one two three four five six seven
eight there which line up next to it and
when we start at the beginning of the
line we set all these to be zero
either all blank
or all ones depending on how you're
doing it to the matter is we'll just say
zero
and then when we come to actually we
load in these bits
with the ones for the pixels let's say
we're copying that
letter a which we had over there we're
on this line so we're going to load in
these bits
um starting from this so we're going to
have a blank one we're going gonna have
a one in it and one one one one
one
zero
close enough close enough and things in
there we've got zero there now let's say
we want to shift this two places
to the right
what we actually do is we don't do any
shifting at all
we just say well okay we'll read
the most significant bit bit seven from
there
so that becomes bit seven that we use
we use bit six from here
then we can read bit five from here
bit four from there
bit three
two
bit one
and bit zero from there
okay no need to shift it we can just
select those bits and hardware and send
them to the output and what we do is we
could have we want to shift it by three
where we start here and read it and we
just have a basically a switch inside so
imagine the sort of rotary switches you
have the digital equivalent of that
which selects where it wants to read
them from to sort of shift this across
and just moves it so we shift the answer
back because everything we're going to
copy is going to be shifted by the same
amount so rather than shifting the input
we just shift where we read the output
to the left and we get the same effect
what do we do with those left over now
this is where it gets clever so we've
got these two bits left over
so we read the first byte
we shift it by shifting our output
things and then we wired this up so when
we come to read the next byte as it
loads in
those bits there
all these bits
get copied
zero one one one one one one into these
bits over here because now when we read
in from the same place
bit seven is what got what was bit one
over there
in there in the top bit
bit zeros got into what was bit six
those things are copied in there so
again we can build the hardware
to enable us to copy these things very
very quickly so we can design this into
the literature whether it's the amigas
whether it's your ties whichever one it
is by using clever hardware and just
selecting different positions and so on
and then you can write them out
there's the bytes or the words that
you're going to write out at the screen
so the blitzchip can do this much
quicker
than
you could do it in software and in fact
you can optimize it even quicker some of
them will say well actually
you've selected a mode where i'm not
actually combining anything if i'm just
writing the value in there i don't need
to read the destinations value
first
i can just use that
things and then you can combine it so
that's bit blip it's an algorithm that
was developed on the xerox alto machines
for copying regions it was made popular
in small talk as well back in the early
80s and then the computers of the 80s
and into the 90s were using this type of
operation to sort of composite all their
graphics together if you wanted to copy
some text on screen you'd use a bit blit
except you might not because one of the
problems with it is
it's great when the
regions are big because the setup cost
is quite small you have to set up i want
to copy from this block of memory it's
got this size and dimensions things to
this block of memory it's got this size
of dimensions and things
that takes time if you're just copying a
single character eight bytes it's often
quicker to just do that manually on your
cpu because it's the cost is similar
to do it manually as it would be to set
it up but if you want to copy a window
from one side of the screen to another
or you're scrolling a whole line of text
in microsoft word or something
where it's
a lot of text it's much quicker to do it
using the bit blit algorithm and i'm
assuming you know judging by the
machines you've talked about that this
was used a lot for gaming and adding
kind of characters onto backgrounds and
things like that yes exactly i mean one
of the things that the amiga did to make
to act as a good games machine was that
the blitter operations could copy
blitter objects bobs as they were called
around the screen as they needed them to
draw them on screen very very quickly it
would set up the
blitz to do it and often this could run
in parallel to the main cpu so the blitz
could be copying data while you
calculated where the next one was going
to go and then put it on screen in some
form there's limitations because you
can't have two things accessing memory
at the same time
easily but you get some
small form of parallelism
in there and so on to do it the problem
these days why it's perhaps not used as
much is that as we said when you've got
continuous tone images sort of gray
scales 24-bit 32-bit color
you don't want to do doing bit
operations to combine things you have an
eiffel channel
which is a sort of value between zero
and one mapped into a 8-bit or 10-bit or
16-bit value depending on your image
system
and you would then do
similar things in that you'd take the
source image and you would multiply it
by its alpha channel you'd take the
destination image and you'd multiply
that by one minus the alpha channel and
then you would add them together to get
the same sort of effect so you can sort
of think about some of these operations
being done in boolean logic as being
sort of
alpha channels where they're forced to
be either one or zero and then we can do
it with logical operations
do not try this at home absolutely only
try this at home oh yeah that's a very
good try this at home but not anywhere
else at all in some sense remember when
we talked about 3d images you could view
rgb as in some sense 3d so the first
plane is r g and b or vice versa